hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine
and welcome to the end of the world yeah
I'm gonna talk a little bit about that
very tiny introduction only because
someone raised the issue and one of the
comments but before I do so let me tell
you some of my intuitive reasons for why
I think it's the end of the world okay
or we're close to it okay whatever close
means to you okay and here's the
synthesis of some of the intuitive
things that I see maybe you have a
different intuition okay fine I can only
give you mine and here we have them here
we have mr. Elon Musk and he's spending
trillions to try to get to Mars we have
mr. reycarts while and he talking about
eternal life he says that we're just a
few scientific breakthroughs away from
achieving eternal life and then we had
our the other day they inaugurated the
first what is it the gaya Toy Story
upper left there upper right there okay
and then everybody is using masks out
there you know if you want to hear in
Frankfurt you know if you want to go and
buy something you need to wear the mask
the other day jfg I was on his program
and he said that why do I use a mask am
i bowing down to authority the issue is
not that the issue is here in Frankfurt
you know you don't need a mask and I
never wear a mask whenever I can help it
but when you go into a supermarket or
you go into a public transportation like
train or whatever you need to use the
mask
otherwise they won't let you
and other places I think New York so I
haven't have the same mission so you
have no choice either that or you stay
fighting against the system go to jail
and go through all that trouble I think
I don't need all that so yeah I don't
wear masks whenever I can help it but
yeah all this shows to me that you know
there this we live we live in very
uncertain times very different times any
person who's my age or older I'm going
on 68 this year and I'm sure that a lot
of people who are in their 80s
they must be horrified with by what they
see out there it's a little different
than it was in the 1930s and 1940s for
those people who are still around
anyways uh there was a comment we'll
start with fan mail here and this had to
do with the extinction theory by the way
my extinction theory for those of you
who are new I'm saying that we're the
last humans on earth okay and it's we're
the last humans because the economy the
global economy is gonna collapse okay
money will be no more and people
sometimes misinterpret that I'm saying
that trade will be no more there will be
no exchange okay and you say well why
won't there be any exchange well there
won't be any exchange because
hunter-gatherers don't exchange okay
a lot of these people don't realize that
we invented exchange in the Neolithic
maybe Mike best guess maybe 5,000 6,000
maybe 7,000 years ago when we went from
subsistence agriculture to commercial
agriculture that's when we started
exchanging this guy made was a I don't
know cobbler and he made shoes and the
other guy liked the shoes that he may
and they started exchanging things until
then it was a subsistence agriculture
before then it was only hunter gathering
we killed some animal out there and we
lived another day that's how it was so
so exchange trade Commerce that's a
that's a new invention of
of our species we invented it maybe I
don't know again five six seven thousand
years ago at most okay so what is the
issue the issue is that people can't
relate to a world without exchange
without trade without Commerce okay and
this fellow wrote the following says
money is an efficient system no doubt
about it I don't dispute that at all in
an exchange between two parties one side
has the money and ability to make loans
and the other side has some value to
offer if we have no money
Godwin's a when a wand and all the money
disappears there will still be value
value will never go away and you know
what can I say value and every time I
hear that word value I know I'm talking
to a Disneyland economist who has very
little understanding of the natural
economy he's never been in the wild or
anything like that you know
no hunter-gatherers they don't know
anything about value all they know is
about food that's the only thing of
value okay and just any animal out there
just you pick it at random wow the
animal the only thing he cares about is
food he doesn't use this notion of value
you know like Tigers don't exchange with
lions or
Lions with hyenas you know a gazelle
there's no exchange like you give me the
gazelle and I'll give you the this
wildebeest or something no such monster
in in the wild no exchange they're
stealing yeah I've seen hyenas steal for
especially from weaker animals such as
what is it
cheetahs because they're smaller animals
and the cheetah just runs away you know
because the hyena is a bigger animal so
they're stealing an opportunist that's
theirs that's there but there's no trade
you only think you only thing you're
going to trade is your life if you stick
around or fight for it okay and yeah
these people don't understand that
anyways why do you think the global
economy is going to
laughs here I'm gonna go real quick
through this a little synthesis here
this is the world population growth
rates for people we are beat we are
producing fewer and fewer children on
the planet
okay that was foreseeable okay that that
would happen and since 1963 the last
year where we had the highest point
which was at 2.3 I think it was yeah
around 2.3 you know that's dropped to
about 1 in this day and age and it's
going to drop to zero rate growth rate
right by mid-century sometime if
everything continues as it is and why is
that important because to the economy
because demand is ultimately an issue of
population you have no population there
is no demand ok and people don't always
understand that they you know they they
think it's a question of quality if I
make a better product while people will
want that product and again that's
Disneyland logic ok now we don't care
about quality we don't care about
technology we don't care about any of
that the issue here is if you don't have
people you will not have demand in the
end quantity is ultimately dependent on
demand and right now we're we're killing
demand because we're not having people
we're not producing people why aren't we
producing people because we went from
the country to the city there's there's
a trend there was a transition there's a
transition still going on in many
countries where people are abandoning
the farms especially to bear big
agricultural corporations and moving to
the cities ok because life is better for
whatever reasons and so this migration
to the city is leaving the country in
the hands of fewer and fewer people and
when you're in the city you have no kids
city is not a place to have kids we had
kids when we were in the country not in
the city so that's that's going on
that's unstoppable we can't revert that
process predictable we know we're gonna
have fewer and fewer children in the
future we know all this already ok and
there's nothing we can do about it
humans with other intelligence all their
technology they can't fix the population
problem ok and some people say
it's good that we don't have more
population because that way we don't
destroy the environment and bla bla bla
bla bla now we're talking about the
economy the economy is you need people
in order to have demand period and
here's global GDP gives you an idea of
since 1980s it's going up and it's in
proportion essentially two or parallel
to the number of people on the planet we
we're still growing as far as people
population wise right on the planet and
that trend more or less mimics that
trend okay but what's the latest trend
well the latest trend you can see in the
last few years 2006 2018 we've been
rather flat on GDP global GDP growth and
for sure with this coronavirus it didn't
help us at all it gave us maybe just
maybe okay maybe gave us the current
across the straw that broke the camel's
back so to speak you know that's the
starting point
of now a relatively short period in
which our economy will go up and down
for sure but always going lower and
lower lower yeah that's that's what I
think is gonna happen but again that's
my opinion
okay only this is my view of what we can
expect as far as global economy okay
we're at that point we're still up there
and pretty soon the economy is just
gonna go south gonna go down to zero and
what does that mean means that nobody
will exchange anything because the only
thing of value will be food okay that's
my take take it or leave it if you had
the intuition to understand that fine
then you reach your own conclusions okay
and help you any further than that I can
only give you my personal view on this
okay the scientific part which is not my
personal view now that we're talking
about science now science is objective
all the past species died because of
food they died because of starvation
they died when the ecological pyramid
overturned and he and you had the many
chasing the few okay so what died was
primary production case of the dinosaurs
the most famous one we can just mention
it just as an example the cycad cycads
William sonja's and so on all those
those forests those jungles disappeared
almost I showed the graph in past chats
and as they disappear or those what I
call shrinking Islands and imagine a
jungle and it shrinks like in Brazil now
they're burning off doing a lot of slash
and burn so the Amazon jungle is
shrinking and whatever animals are in
there they're caught in this shrinking
Ireland that's more or less what
happened to the dinosaurs and yeah when
that happens you have fewer species and
fewer members within each species okay
so it's the ecological pyramid
overturning and that's what I was going
to happen to man his ecological pyramid
is gonna overturn because we produce our
primary production we produce it and we
produce it why because of money because
of exchange because of trade because of
Commerce okay so that's the issue that's
why it's the global economy I say that's
gonna trigger the starvation of man most
people others will die for cannibalism
or who knows what other killing murder
there's there can be all kinds of fun
stuff at the end of the world okay okay
so let's get on with a subject matter of
today but it starts out with some
comments some comments that were made
with respect to my interview with jfg on
what was it on Sunday and we were
talking about what is space layout what
is space in other words right now we
have the mathematical physics
first version and that says that space
is something it's a physical object made
of particles today and an active
participant in physical processes that's
that's the notion that mathematical
physics has concluded with okay and the
question is the first question is that
or the issue here is that mathematical
physics has never defined what an object
is what a thing is what something is
what an entity is what a body is they
never defined that they say uh you know
whatever body a you know what a thing is
no I don't please define what a thing is
and they've never done that what they do
use is the informal version that we use
in ordinary speech which is see and
touch yeah you touch you touch the table
the table is an object you see the moon
the moon is an object the problem with
that is that you need someone to do the
seeing and touching you need another
object and again the moon is not an
object until the asteroid hits it that
means you need the asteroid for the moon
to be an object and the asteroid is not
an object until it hits the moon either
so as long as the asteroid doesn't hit
the moon either one is an object they
only become objects as soon as one hits
the other that's what they're saying and
that's why you can't use the see touch
criteria okay or criteria right to
define the word object for the purposes
of physics okay
and instead I propose that we use the
word shape okay that's gonna bring some
nasty debates here okay so let's
continue here's the first comment it's
related to that okay so we're gonna
start with the comments and this fella
he says be I won't read all that I guess
because he says he's been following me
for many years and he likes what I say
and then he proposes something in
exchange and what he actually proposes
is that we
in Reverse that spaces something and the
objects are nothing the atoms are
nothing atoms are holes like in Swiss
cheese in in a in a something called
[Music]
space and again the problem with that
you know again is is that you know
people don't define what an object is
see if you define an object as that
which has shape right
what contains this Spacey thingy know
what's outside of it
that that's where you have a problem
with that notion okay and so again you
know the it makes me wonder if these
people understand sometimes what I'm
saying out there ok another comment
along the same lines follow says they go
through each other to referring to the
ropes or to the threads I'm not sure
which one you was talking about exactly
they don't entangle because touch and
see is not probably are not a properties
of these ropes ok ropes that's really
yet he explains magnetism me right
saying that Magnus repels because ropes
push each other way what a load of
[ __ ]
and then he says looks like a
one-dimensional concept
Goethe says it's BS yet he does the same
[ __ ] ok so what's the issue the issue is
an object is not that which can you can
see or touch and people don't understand
that because they they want to bring in
the notion of ordinary speech
what's the notion of ordinary speech
it's the C touch criterion and that's
someone the mathematicians use and
that's what they bring in there they say
well if we can see it and touch it we
can go to the lab we can test that we
can measure it and that's what an object
is to them and that's not what an object
is to mother nature mother nature made
her objects her immediates
for gravity for magnetism light cetera
made them invisible and intangible and
so that means there's no object out
there because it's in
and intangible and or intangible yeah we
can't see the air we can touch the air
you know I touched something but I can't
see it and there are other gases you
can't see either
for example phosphine you know we we
dealt with these gases in in the
semiconductor industry and and so you
know you don't see these gases and
they're not made out of atoms the
there's nothing there and so just
because you can't see it it doesn't mean
it is not an object it it's not made of
something it's it's not something can't
you you know you can touch it but you
can't see it it's like touching a ghost
go or something or whatever right an
angel and then you know the the ones
that mother nature uses they're
untouchable also they're intangible and
so you can't go to the lab to try to
prove their existence okay you can't say
there's nothing there because you can't
see or touch it because an object is
that which has shaped not a knob an
object is not that which you can touch
or see and that's where the problem
comes in when people bring in this touch
see criteria to deal with something that
the it's only property is shaped okay
that's gonna be the context here and no
it's not a one-dimensional concept
there's no such thing as a
one-dimensional concept because a
concept is not a body and so you can't
talk about the one-dimensional
two-dimensional three-dimensional
concept
love does not have dimensions okay it's
a concept and there's no such thing as
one-dimensional love maybe in poetry
maybe an ordinary speech not in physics
and so no it's a rope is a physical
object a thread is a physical object why
because they have shape and if they have
shape all these objects are
three-dimensional although we just can't
see them or touch them because that's
not the criterion to determine what
Mother Nature made specifically
intangible and unseeable okay so here's
another
comment along the same lines if space
has no shape then what is there between
two atoms and he answers with my answer
in other words this is a separation with
a rope bill states that in between
objects atoms is distance which is a
rope
yeah good he answered the question so
what's the problem he answered the
question with my my answer what is he
referring to well here's the rope model
for those of you who are not familiar
with it okay you have two atoms and
they're pumping okay they're doing their
quantum jump and what is the quantum
jump it's just the expansion and
contraction of the electron shell around
the proton star okay
and when it does that I'm not gonna go
into the atom right now but what it does
that it torques the rope that connects
any two atoms in the universe okay any
two hydrogen atoms in the universe so
they're pumping and when they pump when
they expand and contract they torque the
rope that's that's light okay so light
is mediated by a rope and it's torsions
along the rope which we're gonna call
light okay so that's the model okay okay
let me get myself back in here and see
if I can get my Soviet and so here we
compare the quantum model against the
rope hypothesis the atom okay here's the
two the first one is by mr. Rutherford
which I showed the other day single
electron bead that orbits a nucleus the
only thing Rutherford has to tell us is
what is between the two particles and he
says he answered empty space that's
what's in between there he doesn't even
say feel he just says empty space and if
it's empty space then the question is
what keeps the electron bound to the
proton under the rope model here you
have 2d and the 3d version 2d version
it's you see a star in 3d version you
see a star that's what the proton is
it's encapsulated by this shell which we
call the electron shell okay
and that shell expands and contracts by
doing so it torques each one of those
ropes that's converging the
upon our atom every atom in the universe
provides a rope to our atom because all
atoms are interconnected by what we call
electromagnetic ropes okay that's the
model okay and so now you see a big
picture here of this and you see why
distance is the length of a rope under
the mathematical physics version every
atom is an independent entity just
floating out there right and this is
just that separation it's not even
distance because mathematical physics
measures everything and they give you a
value they say so many feet so many
inches and that's not what distance is
that's distance traveled what the
mathematician has done is unrolled a
measuring tape under the rope model
distance is simply separation between
two atoms and since all atoms are
interconnected by the electromagnetic
rope distance equates equates exactly to
the length of the electromagnetic rope
okay so that's what he was referring to
and yeah that's the answer yeah so no
problem there I guess as long as he
understands that he can then believe or
not believe what what the proposal is
but at least the important thing is to
understand it not to believe in it yeah
okay and here's another comment and says
the rope can cannot be observed yeah
intangible and invisible yeah this is
similar to stating that the fourth
dimension which is outside our 3d
sensory capabilities well no this has
nothing to there is a difference first
there's a big difference the differences
dimension is not a physical object so
it's not that we can't see the fourth
dimensions you cannot see a concept and
the Rope is not a concept a rope
anywhere in the universe the rope that
the Klingons have on the other side of
the universe it's a physical object this
is a rope okay this is a rope okay and
no anywhere in the universe a rope is a
physical object a tree is a physical
object a table is a physical object all
these
object but that mensch is not an object
it's a concept so you can't say you're
gonna try to see a dimension the fourth
dimension or third dimension you can't
even see the third dimension because you
don't see dimensions you see objects
okay so that's the problem there okay
but then yes rope cannot be observed
first because we don't use observers in
science okay and object has shape all on
its own without any observer the moon
had shape before any of us was born okay
we weren't there to observe it and so we
don't need observers in science we just
need to identify the objects okay that's
the first one the other thing is that
you know ropes the electromagnet you
know this rope this rope is tangible and
it's also seeable you can see it you can
you can it's not invisible and it's it
is visible and it's tangible okay but
this is just an example of shape not of
see touch this is this is an analogy for
shape of what mother nature uses between
two atoms to do light to do gravity as
well as we've seen in previous videos so
the only property that this represents
is shape not see touch and when people
see this they say hello how come I can
can't touch your rope well because
that's the wrong criterion I come how
come I can't see it because of the same
thing yeah that's the wrong criteria
that you're applying okay and okay so
yeah I know no tangibility knowing no
visibility no no no that and yeah what
you have to do is define these words
okay let me let me put this fellow back
up there there it is so he says Rho
cannot be observed and do you see a
provision for observing in the
definition of something something is
that which has shape okay those are the
synonyms there and nothing is its exact
opposite that which doesn't have shape
these in two words are antonyms okay and
so what this tells us is that we can now
use them consistently okay we can use
them consistently in any dissertation
because you know what is the opposite of
the other and so you can say okay what
is something well something that which I
say what is nothing that which doesn't
have shape very straightforward we're
very kindergartner nation you can't
understand that I don't know okay so
nothing otherwise known as space
otherwise known as vacuum you know not
the quantum vacuum we're talking about a
genuine you know scientific vacuum okay
is nothing and nothing is that which
doesn't have shape all the objects that
are within space we call it within space
for lack of a better term they're really
what what the objects are all atoms and
all these atoms have location with
respect to other atoms not with respect
to space because there is no such thing
as space okay atoms only have a
relationship to other atoms they only
interact with other atoms they have
gravity with respect to other atoms they
send light with to other atoms none of
that has anything to do with space
because there is no physical object
called space space is nothing and
nothing is that which has no shape so
all that black stuff you see between the
earth and the moon that's nothing
there's nothing there okay and so it's
when these mathematicians talk about
empty space you wonder what they're
talking about you know and some people
have suggested but they're saying that
empty space is just a lower volume of
particles like if you vacuum you know
remove stuff out of a chamber and now
you have not complete empty space but
what you have is a reduced number of
particles in there they call that empty
space some people say no we don't have a
notion of what empty space is because
they never defined a word nothing and
that's what you got to define they never
done that in 10,000 years okay here's
another comment always getting to the
subject matter today and this is space
is then infinite as there are there is
nothing that lies beyond
okay nothing we have an infinite and
nothing's beyond this infinite the the
first problem there is that infinite is
an adjective and the word infinite in
physics can only use be used with
respect to objects and you can't say an
infinite object because all objects are
finite so the word infinite is an
irrational term anyway you look at it we
can't use the word infinite for anything
else it's an irrational term it was
really creative for mathematics because
they would talk about infinite numbers
that sort of thing that comes at least
from the Greeks if not earlier okay so
when you talk about infinity you're
talking about counting incessantly they
call that infinite infinite infinite
numbers or infinity okay well no one's
ever been to infinity because nobody's
ever counted forever to find out what
the last number is and of course there
is no such monster so that's what they
mean by infinity no we can't use in the
word infinity in science and anyone who
used it to make this cases doesn't
understand that it's not familiar with
the argument okay so yeah all objects
are finite so there is no such thing as
an infinite object and his space is an
object you cannot say that this object
is infinite and if it's not an object if
it's a concept you can't talk about an
infinite concept what are we talking
about here endless love I mean what is
this infinite concept
well infinite intelligence I don't know
you know it can be an object absolutely
not that is infinite again you know you
can't have concepts that are infinite
there's only two types of terms objects
and concepts those are the categories of
terms that for every word in the
dictionary can be put under one or the
other category and I think I've got it
here let's see all words in the
dictionary can be divided into two
categories objects and concepts object
to be point to concept we define we can
point to objects because they have shape
concepts no object has no concept has
shape so there's nothing to
- and as your definition of concept a
word that invokes our embodies two
objects or two words treated as objects
for example the word object the word
object requires - two thingies a
contrast okay and what you have is the
shape and something that gives contrast
to that shape and we treat that contrast
that that a backdrop does what's in the
background that gives it shape we treat
it as if it were an object that's why
universe consists of object objects
right matter and space it's a word it's
a concept we caught universe and it has
these two members these two components
objects which have shape you know matter
and space which we treat as if it were a
physical object giving background or
contour to the atoms that's that's what
what that's what exists that's what we
have out there that's the word universe
okay okay anyways so so yeah the the
issue is defining and you know here we
have the notion that people have gate
also for this fellow okay and that's
typically what we identify with space or
a lot of people identify with space they
say look space is that stuff here in the
center that all those white things those
particles always identified also with
the ether okay because they say the
ether is is space or is contained within
space and those are two different
arguments okay
but either way what they're saying is
that there's some black stuff that gives
contour to each one of those particles
and so the issue is not identifying the
white stuff we can all deal with that
the question is what's the black stuff
that gives shape to each particle that's
the one you need to identify and you
can't identify that you've got nothing
and then we have infinite space okay
here's here's the infinite space version
okay
it never ends it ends in here because I
in my show here because I could not make
it infinite for you sorry so I had to
put a little draw you know frame around
it okay but you have to think of this as
infinite so what do you mean infinite
you mean this just extends extends
extends what is it a question of running
to the edge of the universe or what what
do you mean infinite space and yeah
that's that's the notion they have this
is the so called infinite space that
people have in their minds and the
question is you know how many particles
are there they say well it's an infinite
number of particles okay that's what
that's the notion these people have and
you know there's two notions there as
well by the way okay and the Greeks had
that problem as well what is are we
counting the number of particles is it
to infinity the until you die or
whichever comes first or are we talking
about the whole shebang being extended
eternally err incessantly or whatever so
these are two different notion number of
particles and the whole shebang being
extended you know what they call
infinitely and again you can't have that
because all objects are finite okay so
you can't talk about infinite and
infinite object because you don't even
know that if it's an object if it's
infinite if you can't see its shape you
got to see it from a bird's eye
perspective and then the number of
particles you know more or less the same
thing because it's got to have a shape
and if it has shape it has borders and
it has borders whatever's in there it's
got to be finite finite number of
particles okay under the rope model the
there's only a single thread in the
entire universe that's all there is this
converts to atoms and ropes ropes and
atoms all around and so the amount of
matter is constant because there's a
single thread in floating out there what
you could say in space in nothingness
okay in other words the atoms float with
respect to each other that's what I'm
really
say okay so what is an object let's go
back to that so we can get back to the
word shape okay that's what we're trying
see you today this is what an object is
not an object is not that which you can
see it's not what you can touch not mass
it's not volume it's not motion it's not
made of what we call me ology okay you
can't introduce you can't say that air
is a bunch of particles you know that's
not the definition of an object the if
we're gonna say that air is an object
okay a thing and a lot of people have
problems with that word object there
they say what do you mean air is an
object I thought the table was an object
yeah but there's no difference between
table and air no difference whatsoever
air is a bunch of molecules and atoms
right and that's what a table is so are
you gonna say oh this table is three
trillion atoms or whatever three three
trillion molecules is that what a table
is no a table is what you point to and
you can put to the air as well yeah you
can put into the air officially the air
around the earth it forms a shell around
the earth that's the shape of air and if
you don't like that well you can tell
your friend the astronaut to take a
little balloon out there in the middle
of space okay with air in it pop it and
if you could color code that air so that
you could see it you would see a blob
that blob is made out of atoms so air is
an object because air is made of
molecules and atoms not because of that
but because it has shape when you pop
the balloon and then you have the blob
out there that blob and say what is the
shape of it that's not the question the
question is does it have shape we don't
ask what is the shape of energy we ask
does energy have shaped does mass have
shape that's the issue okay so it's a
yes or no type of question yeah
again we don't use a temporal notion you
know seeing it through parts again Marie
ology it can't be an object it's not
that which is a subject of a sentence
it's not any noun that you
think of the word motion the word orbit
the word itinerary
none of those qualify as nouns for the
purposes of physics we have to
distinguish the language here we have a
new language and people have to be in
tune with the language if they want to
understand okay and so what is a noun in
ordinary speech is not a noun in
rational science why because you cannot
introduce those words which are concepts
in ordinary speech and introduce them as
nouns in physics in physics only objects
qualify as nouns you can't say the mass
a field a a a or the wave you can't say
that because those are all concepts so
you can't use those words as physical
objects you can't treat them as physical
objects they cannot serve as nouns for
the purposes of physics they it's you're
bringing ordinary speech into science
when you do that and a lot of people say
well bill you're doing a lot of
semantics I want to do the physics
science is about explaining phenomena
physical phenomena you need to explain
the mechanism if you're gonna explain
the mechanism you need objects you have
to be able to distinguish between an
object and a concept between what has
shape and what does not have shape and
if you can't do that well you got to
start there that's your kindergarten
work okay you got to go through
kindergarten an object is not that which
has color an object is not that which
exists a lot of people confuse an object
with that which exists and here I'd like
to show this mr. Hume and mr. Kent
Kant whatever Hume said and this was
what 1739 the idea of existence then is
the very same with the idea of what we
can seem to be existent to reflect on
anything simply and to reflect on it as
existent are nothing different from each
other that idea when conjoined with the
idea of an object makes no addition to
it
he could tell the difference between an
object that exists and one that doesn't
so he said object and exists are the
same words are synonyms and Codd a few
years later and said the same thing
nothing is really added to it if I add
that the thing exists okay and yeah to
this day people who I guess have not
read either one of these two so-called
philosophers they make the same error
they think that an object is that which
exists which you can touch which you can
see you know that that's the notion from
ordinary speech and we're debunking all
that we're saying look you know if you
come into physics it's a genuine physics
not what the mathematical physics do
physicists do you have to do you have to
have a different notion you have to
separate the word exist from the word
object these are two different words one
has very little to do with the other one
and a difference is that exist in order
to exist you must have location so it's
an object that has location that's what
exists means there are objects that
don't exist you know a plane for example
such as a square or a triangle that's an
object for the purposes of physics
because it qualifies with shape it has
shape okay but it's an object that
doesn't exist because there it what
exists is the pencil or the the ink
right and the paper but not the triangle
okay
triangles don't exist so here you have
an object that doesn't exist Superman
doesn't exist he's an object
he has shape but he doesn't exist
because at least a cartoon character
were he's two-dimensional you know Snow
White she doesn't exist either okay and
they're not concepts they're objects
because they have shape that's different
than love love doesn't have shape and
people don't always capture these
notions too Swift for them okay so we
come down to what mr. uh
let me get this out of here come down to
what mr. jf had a problem with and he
questioned me about it he said shape and
so he asked me
what do you mean by shape and at the end
of this program he made a comment he
says you know he was disappointed that I
did not define the word shape so what's
my answer to that and that's what the
show today is about really the key point
and here my arguments against it okay in
a nutshell okay and so the first one is
we have the devil's advocate okay and
these are extreme doubles advocates what
they have happened to them they lost the
war and so they're looking for vengeance
they're not constructive they're
destructive and I'm gonna go over that
in a second here
there are other people who genuinely
want to know you know what the arguments
are because they're not aware of what
the arguments are why aren't you
defining shape bill I mean you said that
an object is that which has shape now
you're not gonna tell us what shape is
what's the reason what's why are you
doing that okay and the answer to that
is it's irrelevant that's gonna be the
argument okay I'm gonna get that in a
second here if we do not define shape if
for whatever reason we happen not to be
able to define the word shape does that
mean we go to the default which is the
mathematical physics version or the
version of ordinary speech are we going
to say that oh then we were gonna go
with C touch and that means weren't were
we're not even going to define C and
touch a B what if I ask you what do you
mean by C what do you mean by touch and
and what if I badger you to you know and
play my role as devil's advocate and ask
you to define those terms could you
define them but see when you when you
try to debunk the word shape as a def is
the criterion for defining the word
object what you're really doing is
saying well see you couldn't define it
bill or you didn't want to define it so
I'm going back to see touch that's what
you're saying in a sense in essence
you're going back to see touch because
that is the default Nets that the
fault we need to destroy we need to
debunk that notion there's the issue of
2d vs. 3d shape versus form a lot of
people have questions with that and then
the other issue the final issue will be
that shape is a property it's an
attribute of an object so the words
shape and object are not synonyms okay
an object has shape it's that Universal
property of all objects okay let's go
with the first one devil's advocate what
happens you go in there and you defined
a word the word object okay and you say
it's that which has shape and so you
throw the ball to the other guy and you
say okay you define object what's your
definition you know you know what's the
alternative and so this is where it all
starts and the first thing we say is
that you know we don't we don't define
every word in physics in science we just
defined a crucial words okay that's the
first thing we we tell this person okay
the devil's advocate we don't define
just to please the devil's advocate and
the issue is not definitions of for the
sake of defining the issue is criterion
or criteria that's what that's the issue
before us what is the criteria that
we're going to use to define the word
object for the purposes of physics and
so when you say shavin the other guy
says well what do you propose an
exchange and so they come up with all
these words that I came up with earlier
they say well it's that which we can
touch it's that which we can see so you
show him show the error of his ways okay
you say well to touch you need another
object to see you need another object so
again the moon is not an object until
the asteroid hits it advise versa and
until they hit each other no not objects
obviously you don't need to have an
interaction with two objects to define
one object so that's where all these
notions die is it with that which has
mass mass is a dynamic Khan
whether you count atoms you know
quantity of matter or whether you
accelerate it under special relativity
and go with relativistic mass you're
talking about motion and motion is a
word we define after we define the word
object only objects can move so you have
to define the word object before you
defined the word motion or the word
exists for that matter and so on and so
forth
distance whatever you need to define the
word object and you can't do physics
without objects so you must define the
word object so I had a long run
discussion with a thumb goes by the
moniker dr. Dave and and this fella you
know he badgered me for several weeks on
the word I'm the word shape and and why
did he do that because he could not
define the word object so I badgered him
on the word object right back to him and
he never was able to define the word
object in fact he ended up saying that
we do not need to define the word object
for the purposes of physics now so hold
it what do you mean you don't need to
define the word object we can't do
physics without objects and that's where
these people say well no physics is not
about mechanisms essentially that's what
they're saying it's not about causes
physics is about math about making
equations science essentially is a
process a process of what it's a process
of discovery you know you spend the rest
of an eternity just discovering and
never finding that's their notion of
science and so all they need to do is
describe and they can describe without
having objects they can use point
particles or whatever they want to fit
in there okay and so we don't have a
physical interpretation we don't have a
mechanism of how this universe works
because these people don't know what
physics is they have a different notion
of physics which is math which is
measurement which is developing
technology and that's their notion of
physics of science and so we have a
problem because we're not communicating
okay because we start out with different
notions or definitions of what science
and what physics are
okay that's where it starts and so he
said that he didn't think that he needed
to define the word object so that's his
answer to it because you know when you
put them against the wall say well
you're using well yeah I mean why do
these people give physical
interpretations they give physical
interpretations to their equations well
I do that I mean if they stayed with in
math and do whatever they want to invent
words whatever I don't care
but when they bring these words such as
energy and mass and field into physics
because they're trying to give a
physical interpretation to their
equations to show you that they know and
that their equations give them some
insight into how this universe works
that's where we have the problem we have
a problem that with math we have a
problem with math physics mathematical
physics that's where we have a problem
because these people are bringing their
equations into physics in saying look we
can tell you how this universe works and
you say you can't and they say yeah we
can't see the other day I mentioned the
earth dragging space around
how can you drag space around in space
is nothing and is there no space of
something well then we need to define
these terms to find out what you mean by
nothing or by something that's one issue
the other one is you can explain why the
earth doesn't fly away out of the solar
system for example right and they say
time is warped
that's why earth rules around war time
that's what they're telling you so what
do you mean warp time time is not a
physical object well we don't understand
it either but that's what our equations
tell us and that's what we proved with
our experiments so we have a problem we
have a problem because they're giving
you a physical interpretation in order
to give you a physical interpretation
they have to introduce objects they have
to introduce the earth they in turn have
to introduce the Sun so they have to
tell us what those objects are what is
an object and then they turn concepts
such as time and space into physical
objects in order to accomplish their you
know to be in in consistent with their
equations and with their physical
interpretations and so now we have a
problem because now we need to define
these terms and to say that he doesn't
need to define the word object is only a
cop-out
and why because he wants to harp on the
word shape because he's know he's beaten
and at that point he's got he's got to
try to get back at you he's got a it's
just vengeance that's all it is there
there's nothing constructive it's just
he wants to show you that no matter how
you twist and turn it
you're gonna need words to define the
word shape and then he's gonna say well
what do you mean by this other word what
do you mean by that other word then
you're gonna have to you have this
monster where you have more and more
words always to define it's you know
there we can use the word infinite for
sure it's to infinity you know so here's
one argument against it let me show it
to you let's see if I can get it here
there it is what it what is an object
well an object is that which has shape
right and so the question is why did he
ask what the word that means or what
what the word which means or what the
word has me why did he harp on the word
shape I mean R is is it easier to
defined a word which for example or the
word has do you understand can you
define those two terms real precisely
very scientifically why did he harp on
the word shape in other words you know
we don't define again words for the sake
of pleasing the devil's advocate we
defined those words that are necessary
where there is a problem where there is
a you know clash and you know the in the
case of the criterion that we use to
define the word object these people
wanted to do see and touch and we say no
it's not seeing touch its shape so now
we have something to compare we have
shape against see touch or against
motion or against mass or against volume
or against noun just any noun any
subject of a sentence now we have a
comparison so we don't have to define
the word shape what we need to do is
know the difference or understand the
difference between shape and motion we
have to understand the difference
between shape and mass we have to
understand the difference between shape
and see touch
because we're choosing a criterion for
the word object for the purposes of
physics that's the issue before us not
the issue of Shape and so when the
person harps in the word shape could be
one of those two groups could be a
devil's advocate which is the majority
of them could be a group of people who
just don't understand why we're not
defining the word shape and I'm telling
you why we don't define the word shape
because it's irrelevant
the issue is comparing shape against
what we have today which is see touch
that's the main issue okay and that's
what you need to understand and to harp
on the word shape and shape and shape
all you're doing is moving from that
second category of casual observers or
questioners or inquires to the devil's
advocate group because you're not
understanding the context the context is
not that we want to bypass the word
shape the context is that we need to
compare shape against mass see touch
that's the issue before us and if we do
not define the word object today you
know we can't we can't leave the
conference room until we do then what
happens if we don't define the word
shape we have the default what's the
default see touch that's what people are
using they can't use that in physics
especially with stuff like the rope
hypothesis the robot mattis's says the
rope has shape it's an object you can
talk about this object you know
binding two atoms my fist being here two
atoms you can talk about that because
you got a physical object between them
why can't you touch why can't you see
the Rope because that's not the
criterion for determining what an object
is but you can't say that these that the
two atoms are bound by love you cannot
say they're bound by a wave you cannot
say that they're bound by what a field
because those are all concepts so you
can't use a concept as a physical
mediator as a cause as a mech
that's the issue okay so why is it
irrelevant it's irrelevant because first
we don't define words for the sake of
defining words we just defined the
critical words the word object is a
critical word it's the first word that
everybody's got to define in physics why
because you can't do physics without
objects and physics is not math physics
is not technology physics is explaining
a mechanism mechanisms can only be done
with objects you can't do a mechanism
with concepts such as field force time
mass or energy that's the issue and so
you can't say I'm gonna do this with
energy no way not in physics maybe a
known to religion of mathematical
physics but not in physics okay so
that's why it's irrelevant it's uh it's
taking the conversation on a tangent and
saying look I'm gonna harp on the word
shape until you define it otherwise I'm
not going to accept your definition okay
you don't accept my definition what are
you gonna put in instead we need to
define the word object what are you
gonna put in there you're gonna put
motion are you gonna put exists are you
gonna put you know see touch that's the
issue issues the word object not the
word shape and here I have a little
summary of that issue as well these are
the key words we need to have for the
purposes of physics okay and they're in
in dark blue there on the right hand
side you see the word object or word
distance the word location motion exists
concept and matter those are the
foundations of physics and you must keep
that order you can't define the word
motion before you define the word object
not in physics you can't define the word
distance before you define the word
object because you need two objects to
define distance okay and so on down the
line so they have to be those are the
foundations and they have to be in that
order okay and do you see the word shape
in there in any of those dark blue words
no because shape is not a key word okay
shape simply is a criterion to compare
against see and touch that's the main
point but
you can compare it against mass you can
compare it against any of the other
words that they use okay
okay another issue let me get this back
in here another issue here is 2d vs. 3d
you know some people say well an object
is that which is 3d that's in ordinary
speech you're bringing the notions of
ordinary speech into science into
physics you can't do that it up in in
science and physics it's black and white
there are no three four or five
categories there's only black white on
and off
yes four no okay it's got to be black
and white so that people see the
difference you can't you know muddle it
by saying oh you've got these ten
different categories no that that's okay
for philosophers that they know no
better
okay that's fine now in physics it's got
to be black and white on and off on or
off yes or no okay and so you know
what's interesting in Spanish you know
we don't have the word shape we use the
word form for everything and I'm
probably in other languages as well so
you know there is no word for shape
shape is typically used as 2d
two-dimensional in ordinary speech and
mathematics and form is usually used for
3d that's in ordinary speech in other
words in religion in physics there's
only shape and no shape shape and form
are perfect synonyms it's an outline
it's a contrast call it whatever you
want
that's all shape is that's all form is
okay so don't tell me that oh but you're
talking about 2d and 3d and we don't get
into any of that
okay form shape or synonyms and so there
is no such thing as 2d and 3d shape when
we talk about 3d shapes okay we
typically typically talk about objects
that exist okay so if you have a table
which you drew okay and it's on a 2d
platform in other words on a sheet of
paper and you just drew it that's a
table you point to it and say table
so you gave it the word table to
designate it well that's not the same as
the 3d table where you your coffee to
drink your coffee every morning or eat
your breakfast okay that's a different
kind of table than the one you drew
they're both tables but this is a 2d
table it doesn't exist and this is a 3d
table and that does exist okay
and what's the difference between them
the 3d table has location the table has
location with respect to the remaining
matter in the universe okay so that's
what that's where the word exists comes
in with 3d shapes that exist now not
with 3d shapes that don't exist the
shape that the table I'm imagining you
know that's a table too
okay I'm just imagining I'm dreaming
about it right that's a table and if I
dream up a tree that's a tree what did
you dream about last night bill I dreamt
about a tree and the Apple that fell on
Newton's head okay the Apple was 3d
Newton was 3d and the table in the tree
was C 3d in my mind okay but they don't
exist and a cube a perfect cube ideal
cube its 3d conceptually right but it
doesn't exist either okay so there are
3d objects that don't exist both objects
we refer to do exist and the other the
final point here is that you know shape
is a property of an object so an object
in shape and in shape yeah are not
synonyms not perfect synonyms okay what
we have here object is a category of
words okay every word in the dictionary
again can be defined deep divided
between objects and concepts objects
those which have shape concepts those
those which don't have shape among other
things but the definition is it's a
relation between two objects that's what
a concept is okay and so a relation has
no shape okay and you need an observer
yeah there you need an observer to tell
me you know what the relation is so
there are only two categories of words
if it has shape it fall
under objects okay and shape as well as
the word object for that matter object
as a concept and so as the word shape
it's a concept but shape is a property
of objects okay shape is the universal
property of objects so they're not
perfect synonyms okay
it's like saying all these objects have
the color red well red is not a physical
object okay red is a qualifier of these
objects it's something they have in
common some property an attribute and
shape is something is more or less like
that shape only tells you what property
all objects have okay and that's you
know this what this word is used for
okay so again you know we don't define
just to please the devil's advocate we
don't define every word in existence we
just define those that make or break our
theories and those that we need to
define to give our dissertation and the
first word you need to define in physi
is the word object because you can't do
physics without objects because physics
is not about math it's not about
developing gadgets it's not about
technology it's not about measuring
physics is about explaining how mother
nature does especially her invisible
stuff we know all the visible stuff you
know we know how a pulley works we know
how the window program that was that
brick someone's threw through the window
and you know those are physical objects
those we can see and so we say okay I
understood how the window broke I know
how the pulley went up because we see
all the objects where we have trouble is
understanding how two magnets one a
magnet attracts another we have a
problem understanding you know gravity
we let go of the pen and falls to the
floor you know why they go to the floor
because we can't see the mediators
that's the only issue that's all you got
to do is since you can't see or touch
them you can't go to the lab to prove to
yourself whatever gravity is no the only
way is to sit back and visualize what
came in contact with a pen or how two
magnets could possibly be attracting to
each other and when you turn them around
they reject each other you know have
South versus South in one case north
in the other case so so you need to
visualize the physical mediators mother
nature uses yay
that's niche okay with that I'll see you
what is it on Sunday and I hope
everybody stays safe
and don't catch the virus bye bye we'll
see you